Jamie Oliver is our co-host for the
entire show
today thank you for having
me now does anyone recognize this couch
out yeah you do yes you do because this
is literally the couch that broke the
Internet it's Jeremy Allen White's
Calvin Klein commercial shoot this is
the couch not like oh it's you know one
like it it's the
couch he stripped down to those tidy
whes and it has now been watched over 35
million times and behold where Mr White
as a cushion put his little
tokus yeah well listen I mean who better
than Mr Jamie Oliver to talk about a
show about a young hot Chef hello Naked
Chef a few years
ago I mean and then you know you grew up
in the family Pub which made
extraordinary food elevated you know
that was sort of how you matriculated
into figuring out who you wanted to be
at a young age what do you think of the
show The Bear uh I think it's amazing
and I've seen the first couple of shows
everyone's gone wild about it I need to
get into it sometimes when you're a chef
and you watch shows about chefs it's
quite traumatic it's a bit like going to
work it's a bit stressful and like is
that portrayal of kitchen hectic intense
energy it definitely can be like that
but I think when you're trying to get
your heart and soul on a plate and like
it involves so many moves and
choreography it's like a show every day
everything's kind of got a slot into the
right place of course you get lots of
emotion but you know most of us love it
and even though it's painful it it's
it's a beautiful industry what happens
I'm just going to move you over
here just
behind he is he is very lovely um so
lovely everybody thinks it everybody
loves you um okay how did the Naked Chef
come about because that was so brilliant
it's not quite as technical as that but
um no when they asked me to do a TV show
I wrote on a little kind of document I
just want to strip down restaurant food
to its Bare Essentials and a guy called
Ben Adler who was a developer went
stripping
Bear Naked and uh and then we basically
did a whole show about stripping that
down and then everyone thought it was
like a naked cooking show so we had
massive ratings uh and then they were
like mildly disappointed and then uh and
then we cracked on and and somehow
managed to sort of cut through the noise
at the time and you know that was 25
years ago and here we are now it really
did cutch was
annoying like yeah I think so it's yeah
I got lucky I def I wasn't even the
night I got discovered I wasn't even
supposed to be working what someone
called in sick and I I was actually at
home with my Ms and we never really had
time off together that much and I was on
a promise so like it was going to be a
great night everyone's going what's a
promise it's like you know what A
promise is uh and uh and work forone not
said so and so is called in sick you've
got to cover it's a Saturday night we're
fully booked so I went in to my wife's
disappointment
and um and that's when the crews were
there so it was definitely a slide
indoors moment and I've been riding that
wave ever since I didn't know that yeah
yeah okay so speaking of your wife there
is a story that I'm obsessed with you n
you cooked nak oh God that one okay uh
are you ready for this yes okay so um it
was Valentine's Day oh I just I just got
the I've been skin all my life and I got
a first decent paycheck and I I upgraded
my kitchen had this lovely German oven
good technology fan assisted um put a
lovely whole SE bass in there stuffed it
with herbs bit of white wine bit of
olive oil that was good put chardai on
lit the candle you know made the room
look nice laid the table oh yeah I
forgot the bit I was
naked and I and I wanted to dress it up
a little bit for various reason I put a
bow around it and um so
when no I was being creative don't judge
me I open the oven that bling fan
assistant like a shot of steam went
straight on my
todger no girls actually boys you
wouldn't believe like size of a tennis
ball unbelievable I spent I know look at
the faces in the room and then I
basically spent the whole night which
was going to be great with frozen peas
on the crutch just CU I'm so sorry why
did I do this so um listen that is no
that is a true story it's my favorite
story but for the fellas what was
amazing is I've never had pain so bad in
all my life never ever cook naked that
is a public service announcement from
the naked sh you heard it don't do it
right now not even for Valentine's Day
all right so you and your wife like have
been together how many years now uh oh
like 30 so I met her yeah since I was 18
since you were 18 since I was 18 there
you go oh my god there she is five it's
pretty colorful I was only in for two
but she had other ideas so it was a it's
uh yeah five what I know and I have I
one of my favorite of your books
together has you and your whole family
on the cover I have every single one of
your books and this five ingredient
phenomenon that you've come up with this
is five ingredients Mediterranean
exactly if you've got no money in the
Mediterranean they eat well and
certainly in my country if you've got no
money and you can't cook things get
really dark really bad um so I just see
it as saving you money I see it as um uh
making you have joyful times I see it as
helping you live longer a more
productive life I would love if we could
run to the kitchen and cook